hello everyone summer is officially over
as this is the first video I'm doing in
long sleeves but none of that matters as
this next game I have prepared for you
will keep you warm in the coldest of
times this game was played in 1972 in
Germany between Ralph runo and a person
named Schmidt now I have a couple of
ideas who this person was but again I'm
not going to use any photos in this
video as I can't really can you know add
photos with certainty as to who the
players are really are so let's see this
game a Ralph Uno is white and the
schmidt is black and this is this is
such an amazing game you'll just have to
see it
we have efore and Knight to c6 the names
of a defense we have d4 d5 and now II
capture son d5 this is the Scandinavian
variation of the names of each defense
Queen captures Sun d5 and now Knight to
f3 now defending that b4 pawn and the
black plays Bishop to g4 and here we
have a Bishop to e2 so and white black
can't really win a pawn here if you
would play something like a bishop
captures Knight Bishop captures Bishop
and the Queen captures on d4 this
doesn't really work as well you'll
simply play Bishop captures on f c6
would check and black loses a queen here
so this would be a terrible blunder by
black so after Bishop to e2 black played
Queen said castle and we have c4 by
white attacking that Queen black plays
Queen to h5 and now white plays d5 and
we have Bishop captures on f3 and Bishop
captures on f3 and I've been in this
exact position so many times in blitz
games and in board games and I never
think that's the idea that Rolf Runa got
in this game
Schmidt plays Queen to e5 would check
and okay he's checking the black King
and also attacking this B to pawn and it
doesn't really matter that his knight is
attacked since well if he captures on c6
and white loses the Queen but in this
position
Runa played Bishop to e3 he invites
black to capture the b2 pawn and so
black does it
there doesn't seem to be anything wrong
with it so we have a queen capture some
b2 and Runa castles here he's given up a
whole rook we have Queen captures on a1
and now comes the punchline that ruin
ahead
he plays D captures on c6 and Wow I mean
what is this sorcery he's sacrificing a
whole Queen now so of course well why
does capture if he plays black does
capture he plays rook captures on d1 and
now aruna plays C captures on b7 with
check and Schmidt doesn't want to play
Kings to be a to go into rook captures
and e1 with checks if he plays a king to
be 8 and now Rona plays rook captures on
d1 and he's a threatening rook to d8
checkmate so black has to stop this he
plays c6 and white captures the pawn
better captures on c6 so again he's
threatening rock to d8 check with a
promote with a promotion and black tries
to stop this with King to c7 although
although black and white can still go up
to d8 but the white finds an even better
move and this is just this is just
brilliant he plays rook to d7 check and
he forces black to capture the bishop so
we have King captures on c6 and now the
greatest under promotion of all he plays
pawn to b8 with a promotion to a knight
and this is instant checkmate so yeah
this is a this is one one beautiful game
it this game was suggested to me by a
subscriber over my facebook page but
let's just look at that one more time so
this is move 10
this is move 10 white just castled here
we have Queen captures on a1 now D
capture c6 sacrificing the Queen rocket
I mean C capture some b7 but check King
here rugby 1 threatening checkmate c6
captures and boom rook to these 7 check
King captures and b8 night with a what a
beautiful checkmate so yeah I do I do
think that you know you should really
know this game by heart as the someone
who plays the names over to defend
so could get into this well very easily
and I don't know I would be very happy
if I won a game like this and yeah well
it's it's just amazing and I would like
to thank David yeah yeah did see on Joel
Lundqvist and Amit zeal for a
contribution to my channel I really
appreciate it guys thank you very much
and yeah there's one more thing I wanted
to say yeah a lot of people ask me how I
chose the winner of the just one
giveaway no I will do it today at 8 8
o'clock being creation time so in about
in about 9 hours I will make a video
about it and also announce the winner on
my Facebook page
and one other thing I wanted to say what
was it yeah if you ever suggest a game
you know you would like me to show in
the comment section please just use the
word suggest or suggestion so well when
I look for a game that was suggested to
me I can't really remember them all from
the comments so I just searched the
comments which the word suggests or
suggestion and well if you just write
one of those words then I will find your
suggestion because I do get quite a lot
of suggestions so yeah that's it as
usual you can check do all my previous
videos here thank you all for watching
and I will see you soon